a lot to nukes you know I mean the only
countries never nuked anyone was us
let's remember that do you remember him
threatening Joe Barden said of Jobar job
I'd run him yeah and then he said I
would knock out Joe Biden Joe Biden
would go down fast and hard so he said I
talked about in the beginning of my
Netflix special because it was so
ridiculous I was like I want to get in
his ear try to make this happen like
you're great at everything you'd be
great at fighting do it in there bro
don't let her talk watch she's making
fun of your kids to old men like Trump
and Biden fight yeah to the death it
would be amazing it would be amazing
it probably the biggest pay-per-view
event in the history the world of got
mean well what's currently the biggest
pay-per-view Manny Pacquiao Floyd
Mayweather the first fight okay yeah
this would clearly win yeah oh I saw
these old guys go on it yeah they're so
old to think back in Russia my
motherland look at these guys is this
bad grandpa isn't it no this is real
fight yeah okay there's a lot of that in
Russia oh yeah I got fell when he hit
him and then the other guys like [ __ ] I
got you he falls
that's how Ruth Bader Ginsburg broke her
ribs they don't talk about that yeah he
fought with some other [ __ ] yes so to
my heart try to pull a knife on her all
you have to do is have like movement
guys got a good job but it's got no
balance
look those hips are bad too Oh leg kick
this let's synchronize no like modern
dance this is real old dudes guys got no
shoes on - that's probably why he's
doing better
no she just grounded better are you
calling this fight like UFC yeah he's
thinking about sucker-punched him with
the right see see I saw that comment see
I saw that right chopped him karate chop
to in the face oh but you see the guy
tightening up with that right side you
gotta be real careful when you see a guy
moving funny with the right is that car
looked like it was a Kia I think it said
mmm do you know where this is that man
just had like a European man statue yeah
this has gotta be some European country
mmm there's a Twitter account like
something only in Russia and it's just
Russian [ __ ] I look at him like [ __ ]
is my genes